RYAN LOREN: Welcome,
Avery Sunshine, to Google.
It's so good to
have you here today.
I'm so glad to be here.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE].
AVERY SUNSHINE: How you doing?
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm sorry.
RYAN LOREN: No.
AVERY SUNSHINE: I'm
so out of order.
I'm so out of order.
I'm so excited.
Well, you know that.
You know I'm excited.
RYAN LOREN: I'm excited too.
AVERY SUNSHINE: This is huge.
RYAN LOREN: This is going
to be a great night.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Yes, it is.
RYAN LOREN: Just wanted to
have a little chat with you
before we get started.
So, Avery Sunshine.
This is your name.
AVERY SUNSHINE: [LAUGHING].
RYAN LOREN: Can you
tell us about your name?
AVERY SUNSHINE: Well, my
name-- this is so funny.
My partner-- I don't know why
he's not in here right now.
Dana, wherever he is.
But Dana and I, we
worked on-- I never
thought I was going
to be an artist.
I didn't think I
sang well enough,
or I was talented
enough to be an artist.
And Dana was like no,
listen, listen, listen.
I think you've got something.
Let's just start writing
and see what happens.
So the first song we wrote, and
we're going to sing it tonight,
the song is called "Stalker."
And I know.
I know.
But I wrote the hook.
And I said, Dana, I'm going
to send you this hook.
I can't get you out my
mind, and all this stuff.
Just good stuff.
I'm not the kind of
girl who'd stalk you,
but I might call you over
and over and over again.
So we wrote the song.
And a good friend of
his was a house DJ.
And he wanted to remix it.
And he did, and it was amazing.
And he said, OK, we're
about to put the record out.
Who do you want to be?
I was like, what's that mean?
He was like, well, no
you can change your name.
I was like what's wrong
with Denise White.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
AVERY SUNSHINE: Everybody
was like, there's
nothing wrong with
Denise White, but you
could do something
else if you wanted to.
And I blurted out,
Avery Sunshine.
And it's so funny.
When I tell you I never thought
about being an artist before,
I hadn't.
At least I didn't think I had.
And I think it comes from
my love two characters.
First character is Shug Avery
from "The Color Purple."
And then the other character is
Sunshine from "Harlem Nights."
He'd throw it up in the air
and it would to sunshine.
It's all adults in here, right?
There's no children here..
But if you don't know
what we're talking about,
please rent "Harlem
Nights," so you
know what I'm talking about.
In no way am I-- or
whatever the case.
But that's how I got the name.
Just blurted it out.
RYAN LOREN: Well, it suits you.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: Really well.
You know, you have an energy
that's contagious ever
since I met you.
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's coffee.
RYAN LOREN: Is it coffee?
I was going to ask.
I know you've got kids.
I know you're always upbeat.
Is it coffee?
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's coffee.
Because otherwise-- you have
to be with kids and keeping up
with what's going on.
With a career as an independent
artist, you better be.
RYAN LOREN: So for those of you
who haven't heard your music,
how would you introduce
people to your music?
AVERY SUNSHINE: It is--
RYAN LOREN: What's your style.
AVERY SUNSHINE: My
style is R & B soul.
And there's that common thread
of gospel through it all.
But I'm still talking about
my baby daddy, and life,
and stuff.
But I hope that it
makes people feel good,
so I like to call it
feel good music too.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
AVERY SUNSHINE: So I hope it
does make people feel good.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
I think it does.
And I was a little
surprised to hear
you say you weren't
planning to be an artist,
or weren't expecting that.
But weren't you involved in
music at a pretty young age?
AVERY SUNSHINE: I was.
I started playing
piano at eight. .
And I started directing
choirs and playing
for choirs at the age of 13.
So I was reading music.
And I had an aunt, her
name was Aunt Tootsie.
And Aunt Tootsie called my mom
one day and said, listen, Ruth.
Listen, I'm working at
the Catholic Church,
and I can't be
there this Sunday.
I got to Tahiti.
Can Denise come read these this
[INAUDIBLE] service real quick?
And my mom asked me, Denise,
do you want to try it?
And before I knew how much
money it paid, I said sure.
The service was one
hour, and I got $175 just
to go in and read some music.
I was like, I'm through.
That's my career.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
AVERY SUNSHINE: But I felt like
I was always behind the scenes.
I was directing the choir,
or accompanying someone.
And I would sing
out of necessity
if somebody didn't
show up to do a solo.
That's how I would
end up singing.
But never, you know what?
I'm going to sing a solo today.
And I just didn't
think I-- you know,
some people are like that.
You go to church, you know
that one person, yeah, I'm
just going to sing "The Star
Spangled Banner" for the Lord
today.
We didn't ask you to do that.
I was not that person.
I tell you, I am such a fan
of that real, real singer.
The Clark Sisters
and Stevie Wonder.
And I was like,
if you don't sing
like that-- that's
what I thought.
And you've got to
have a thing too.
Because everybody that can
sing doesn't have a thing.
And I didn't think
I had that thing.
I didn't know.
And when I tell you,
this is so divine,
I feel like it just fell on me.
And then Dana and I
met, and it was really--
Dana wave your hand so
everybody can see you.
That's my partner, everybody.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING].
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Yeah, without him,
there would be no
Avery Sunshine.
So feel free to
call him Ike Turner,
Rick James, Joe Jackson.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
RYAN LOREN: Thank you.
So tell me more about the last
album and what it meant to you.
Well, do that first, and then
we'll go to the next question.
AVERY SUNSHINE: The last
album, which was my first,
it marked a point in my life.
I was going through a divorce.
I always say this-- I
didn't go to therapy.
I probably should have.
But the record served
as therapy for me.
I was able to talk about
what I was dealing with.
And I'm going to tell you, if
stuff is better on the outside.
I just believe it.
And I was able to get it out and
to make it to the other side.
So that record marks
that time in my life.
And I'm grateful for it.
I look back, and I'm like, wow.
I'm glad people
liked it, because I
was going through some of that.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
AVERY SUNSHINE: One of
the songs, I was crying.
Dana was like, I
don't know if we
need to put this on the record.
It's like, no, no, but I
just want people to fee me.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
RYAN LOREN: So then, what can
we expect for the next one?
AVERY SUNSHINE: More crying.
No, I'm not going
to do more crying.
A different place.
This next record is going to
be entitled "The Sun Room."
And if you have a
house, the sun room
is that place where
you go put up your feet
and do whatever it is
you feel like doing.
If you feel like talking
on the phone, you do that.
If you want to watch a
little TV, you do that.
If you want to look out and look
at the lake, you can do that.
Whatever it is you want to
do, that's your sanctuary.
And I want to encourage
everybody to find that place.
So this next record is
called "The Sun Room."
And whatever has been on
my mind this last few--
as well as Dana's.
Our minds this last
year or so, that's
what we're talking about.
But it's definitely happy.
RYAN LOREN: Good.
I think the last one-- it's
just interesting to me.
I always thought
it was fascinating
how music is therapeutic.
You said you didn't
go to therapy,
but it sounds like
you sort of did.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Thanks to all of you.
If you have the record, you
helped me with my therapy.
Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: I'm looking
forward to the next one.
So before we go, just a
couple of favorites of yours.
What's one of your favorite
places to see live music?
AVERY SUNSHINE: Oh, what are
my favorite places to see--
RYAN LOREN: In any city.
Wherever.
AVERY SUNSHINE: In any
city to see live music?
I have to tell you London.
Ronnie Scott's.
It's really, really tight.
If you haven't been, please make
a trip to London and check out
Ronnie Scott's.
It's half the size of
this room right here.
And the intimacy, it's electric.
I fell in love with
music again in that spot.
And I hope to play
there one day.
RYAN LOREN: I'm going
to check it out now.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Please do.
Please do.
RYAN LOREN: What's one of your
passions outside of music?
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Directing choirs.
That's outside of music.
RYAN LOREN: [LAUGHING].
AVERY SUNSHINE: No, my children.
My children.
My son and I are movie buffs.
So we have dates.
We try to have
dates once a week,
he and I. And the last date
we had, as a matter of fact,
my daughter was
supposed to come,
and he was feeling some
kind of way about it.
And was like, can you drop
her off to get her hair done,
so we can really have our date?
But I'm taking it seriously.
I want him to-- my dad and I
used to have dates like that.
I want my son to how to treat
a woman or anybody by me
spending that time with
him and showing him.
Not just telling
him, but we do it.
We do it.
And the last movie we
saw was "Superman."
What's the name of it?
AUDIENCE: "Man of Steel."
AVERY SUNSHINE: "Man of Steel."
I was nervous.
It was a little dark.
Who did Clark Kent first?
What was his name?
Michael Reed?
Christopher Reeve.
I'm sold out for
This new stuff.
That's when you know when
you're getting older too.
Like, see this
new fangled stuff.
I'm not that old.
RYAN LOREN: So how
old are your kids?
AVERY SUNSHINE: My son is
11, and my daughter is 13.
And y'all, my daughter, she
wrote a song that's going to be
on [INAUDIBLE] and
"Musiq Soulchild."
Yes.
It's going to be an
interlude on the record.
RYAN LOREN: That's incredible.
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's nuts.
Actually, she played it for me.
And we listened to
the track on my phone.
And we recreated it for her.
And when she heard it, she
was like, it's not right.
So y'all need to do it again.
RYAN LOREN: That's incredible.
Great.
AVERY SUNSHINE: I'm
excited about that.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Last thing.
What was the first CD
you remember buying?
AVERY SUNSHINE: The first CD.
I don't remember buying one.
I I tell you, it's strange.
CDs came out, and I
remember waking up one day,
and there were three
CDs at the house.
There was the Yellowjackets.
And my parents had
the Clark Sisters.
And then there was one more.
Kenny G. [SINGING].
It was.
What's the one?
"The Wedding Song?"
The sound quality from a tape
to CD made your head pop off.
Am I the only one
that remembers?
To hear that, oh what is it?
It just felt like water.
You just feel like there's
life to hear that sound.
It was amazing to me.
I remember those distinctly.
I don't remember buying them.
It's like, just one day
they were at the house.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
They have a way
showing up, right?
AVERY SUNSHINE:
They just showed up.
But I remember those
three CDs distinctly.
And the sound was just amazing.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, there's a fourth one
I'm looking very forward to.
It is yours.
So thank you for joining us.
And looking forward--
AVERY SUNSHINE: Thank
you so much, Ryan.
It means so much to me.
Please make some noise for Ryan.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE].
AVERY SUNSHINE: Because
for all the artists
that are here tonight,
it means so much
for us to be able
to share what we do,
and the way we want to do it.
And we just don't have
the platform all the time.
And I'm speaking for everybody.
We are grateful.
And we're grateful
that you're here
to listen and share with us.
And we thank you, because
you didn't have to.
You could have said,
let me call Beyonce.
RYAN LOREN: I do
sound like Beyonce.
And I have her
number, of course.
But I didn't.
AVERY SUNSHINE: BUt you
could have called anybody,
and chose us.
And I'm grateful.
And we thank you so much.
RYAN LOREN: And likewise.
There's a reason
I chose you guys.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Aw, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE].